how you doing sir
i'm great steve how are you doing
excellent uh congrats on the movie let's
start with that
um i am curious in the background of the
basketball scenes there are so many
warner brothers characters
what's the one that you were like i
cannot believe we get to put this in the
movie
because for me it looked like a
clockwork orange like i couldn't believe
you got to do that
but i'm curious on your end you know
you know there's so much that was going
on with the entire movie i think i would
think i was
less you know thinking about
the the live action that was when we got
to
the visual effects of them where we got
to include scooby-doo and
the flintstones and and and uh
captain caveman and the iron giant um
you know i i i think you know it what
was funny to me was
was seeing the the the different
iterations of
of batman and the joker you know we had
joker from the
you know from the from the television
show we also had joker from
you know from uh uh the tim burton
version of of of
of batman and we had you know and same
thing you know with catwoman and
everything so like that was kind of cool
too so
yeah i know there's such a vast you know
library of characters and movies in no
warner bros you know you know
universe that you know we want to throw
everything in there
uh one of the things that i've learned
is that animators love to include stuff
that the director does not realize is in
the movie
so i am curious if you ever pushed pause
on some of those frames
and really stared in the background
because i'm sure an animator
snuck something in there you know i
haven't found it yet
you know usually most of the time that i
saw everything
um you know it would happen in layers
and
you know i discovered a few things here
and i'm like who's that guy
or who's that girl you know um and
it might be a character that i didn't
even know about before um but like i
wasn't that
wasn't that familiar with space ghost i
wasn't that familiar with um
you know some of these other ones but
but you know for the most part like i
was familiar with
the bulk of these characters so you know
nothing
caught me off guard yet i i have a
feeling something will at some point but
one of the things that i read and i
could be wrong is that you joined this
film when it was already sort of a
moving train you know is already flying
forward
what is it like as a director to sort of
jump on board like a ferrari that's
driving at 100 miles an hour
it wasn't easy um but you know
fortunately i had great support you know
from my producers from the studio
from the great uh artists at ilm and uh
warner animation group that allowed me
to
do my job and bring my expertise to the
to the
to the process and they were able to
help me achieve
you know the vision for the movie so it
was great actually i mean once we got
going and once i understood like
these were all part of the storytelling
that we had that was that was gonna be
makeup of this movie
it was it was much a much easier thing
to deal with
uh everyone at collider uh is uh
obviously huge fans of ryan coogler
and he was involved in this project
early on uh we were all curious
was he involved in this at all when you
were involved like what was his
involvement or was it just sort of
shepherding the project
you know a few years ago well you know
he he he was there um you know
there were you know you know he's a
great cinematic mind
you know uh ryan is is very much
has his finger on the pulse of cutting
cutting
edge technology um you know what's in
the zeitgeist
um he also is great about you know
sounds
and music so you know he was a great
collaborator and great support
system uh every sounding board you know
when it came to
what this movie needed to be so you know
he was he was you know
juggling you know a number of other
projects of black messiah now black
panther
he's got a lot a lot going on but you
know when when he did chime in it was
valuable
and that don't have to stop i'm just
going to say it congrats hope it's a
huge hit for you
uh thank you so much for your time
appreciate it